foreign
[Music]
let's go we got no time to waste let's
get another speedrun game in 1729 with
black Luke c24
okay good luck Luke
hopefully we get a a juicy game and
hopefully we get a main line accelerated
Dragon we will our I'm maybe needlessly
excited but this is only our second Main
Line excited and this is amazing because
we actually get a marozzi bind and the
marozzi bind is the reason why
the majority of people who refuse to
play The Accelerated Dragon what they
most fear and for very good reason is
the marozzi bind the Marazzi bind is
it's both A variation and a structure
and the structure that it refers to uh
is specifically Sicilian structures with
a white Pawn on e4 and a white Pawn on
C4 why is it called a bind well because
these pawns are both aiming at the D5
square and if you watched my previous
video you will know that one of the main
ideas of the accelerated dragon is to
push D5 and liberate Black's pieces open
up the center now this move becomes
virtually impossible why is it called
marozzi uh Gaza marozzi was a Hungarian
player lived I think in the second half
of the 19th century one of the top
probably top 10 top 15 in the world at
his Peak and you know he sort of
developed and described uh this this
concept we stand on the shoulders of
giants now the variation that I want to
show you against the morosi bind is a
very dangerous sideline that slips
through the cracks very often um you
might assume that Bishop G7 here is
automatic right I mean why would you not
feed encounter your bishop and yet there
is a sideline which I think is more
dangerous and more practical for uh
newer players and intermediate players
and this immediately challenges white in
the sense that it gives black chances to
fight for an advantage so what you do is
you actually start with Knight F6 you
delay the fiancettoing of the bishop and
this move should make sense to everybody
here immediately attacking the E4 Pawn
and an important side note is that if
white takes on C6 and then plays E5 and
tries to push this Knight out of F6 this
is a very common trap black has a check
on A5 I'll show that on the board after
the game picking up the E5 font so this
works out tactically now here's step two
and step two might seem odd to people
who've never seen this line before now
you take on D4 and you you send Dwight's
Queen into the center and again this
should look very dangerous to you
because you're allowing your knight to
get pinned and E5 might seem like a very
dangerous threat but concretely this
works out for black and because of E5
it's important to refrain from Bishop G7
here because that walks into E5 so here
you throw in the move D6 and you do that
in order to well obviously you're
opening up the bishop but you're also
halting the progress of White's epon
white can still play E5 but then you
just take it and if white trades Queens
then yeah our King has lost castling
rides but it's not worth the price of a
pawn for white to get that position
this is yeah this is one of the main
lines but it's definitely considered a
sideline in comparison to Bishop G7 here
which is the most popular move anything
that's not the sort of direct path I
call a sideline sideline doesn't mean
it's not commonly played
this means it's less popular than the
main line
now what is the high level idea of
taking on D4 it's actually very simple
after we find keto the bishop Arc the
White Queen is in our crosshairs so
we're trying to gain essentially a tempo
for development by forcing White's Queen
onto an awkward spot So eventually after
we go Bishop G7 white screen is going to
have to back out of D4 there might not
be an immediate threat of a discovered
attack in fact there isn't but after we
complete our development there will be
and we're going to gain a very important
tempo for our development
and it's always not always easy for
white to find a good spot for the queen
moving it all the way back to D1
you know that's kind of
um lame and the queen just doesn't have
all that many good squares these types
of structures
so
we now forget our Bishop to G7 Bishop E2
is one of the main moves
and on the next move we are going to
Castle okay our opponent castles we
Castle as well
and you should note that at this present
moment there is still no threat of a
discovered attack against White's Queen
because Knight takes E4 doesn't work the
queen takes the Knight and gets out of
the discovery same with Knight to D5
right the queen controls both of those
squares but Bishop B3 is a positional
mistake because it allows a third
Discovery and this third Discovery isn't
dangerous because it wins anything it's
dangerous and it's bad for white because
we or we engineer a favorable trade what
am I talking about if you're watching on
YouTube pause the video see if you can
figure it out while there aren't that
many viable squares for the night yes
everybody is pointing out Bishop E3 is a
mistake and I believe that Bishop G5 is
the best move in the position instead or
queen to D1 because we're we're able to
play Knight to G4 and trade our Knight
for whites uh dark squared bishop and
why is that good well that's good
primarily because our Bishop is then
totally uncontested and we've got a
monopoly on all of the dark squares in
the center and you know Monopoly on
squares and chess is very very good I
would say that black is already better
not much better we're not you know
winning or anything like that but we've
we've definitely solved all of our
opening problems after this trade and
we're able now to fight for the
advantage
our Bishop becomes an absolute monster I
mean if you've seen any Sicilian dragon
games you should know that when white uh
gives up their dark Square Bishop for a
night obviously it's different when
white trades his dark squared Bishop for
our dark squid Bishop that's often
favorable for white but an uncontested
dark squared Bishop in any Sicilian
Dragon structures whether it's an
accelerated dragon or or a regular
dragon is often incredibly dangerous for
white both positionally and tactically
okay so now we need to solve the sort of
final opening problem with which we are
faced which is the question of where to
position our light squared Bishop
um and there's there's a couple of
options I don't think there's a very
clear correct answer here
perhaps most of you are thinking either
about Bishop to D7 or maybe about fee
and ketoing that Bishop the reason I
don't like fiend ketoing the bishop is
that why can position the F Pawn to F3
and our Bishop on B7 is just going to be
biting on granite so we want our Bishop
to actually be doing something to be
you know
tangibly contributing to the pressure
and there's really only one square from
which the bishop is able to do that and
it's it's E6 right it's a weird move you
don't play that move often but just
because the developing move is uncommon
doesn't mean you should automatically
throw it out and in the accelerated
Dragon Bishop to E6 is actually a very
common developing move the other option
is to go Bishop to D7 and essentially
prepare a queen Side Pawn break with A6
and B5 expanding the queen side is a
very good plan in these positions
because ultimately we do want to break
into the marozzi bind we want to open up
the center uh so that our Bishops have
more prospects but that's going to come
a little bit later and it's hard to get
B5 in because white can meet A6 with A4
uh so we shouldn't put all of our eggs
in one basket why not E5 before Bishop
B6 well E5 is a very very bad move here
positionally because it closes down the
dark squared Bishop completely right
it's going to be staring into our own
Pawn we want to avoid that and second of
all we create a massive hole on D5 that
white can use as a ready-made Outpost
for his Knight so we definitely want to
avoid pushing our e-pun to E5 in most
circumstances in these marozzi bind
positions there are some exceptions
mostly when we have a knight on C6 that
we can establish on D4 that mixes things
up a little bit but let's just get our
Bishop out in this position
and we get 10 subs from door Johnny
thank you to Johnny for the 10 Subs damn
girl
what I like about the accelerated dragon
is that it's actually quite easy to play
even if you don't know you know all of
the theory or all of the ideas
what are our ideas here well first of
all we're putting pressure on C4
um Rook C8 is is a move that comes to
mind we need to be careful about the A7
Pawn of course so that's why we could
play A6 but you often see accelerated
Dragon players actually go A5 and grab
as much space as possible on the queen
side
and A5 is a positionally risky move
because it does oops sorry because it
does weaken
uh the the B5 square but the B5 square
is not necessarily relevant to the
position as a whole what you have to
understand is an outpost isn't
inherently good just because a piece
sits on a square where it can't be
chased Away by a pawn that's the
definition of an outpost it doesn't make
that piece necessarily good and the B5
Square isn't such a big you know find
for white just because white plays
Knight B5 that doesn't disturb Us in any
way
um so that this is a good application of
that concept which is why we can play A5
really without much worry about its
drawbacks so A5 comes to mind the idea
is to drive the pawn down to A4
and grab as much space as possible and
then we could drop our Queen onto A5 and
just put more pressure on White's Queen
side
so that's one concept we can play A5 we
can play Queen to A5 immediately and
again pressure the Knight pressure the
A2 Pawn just that Queen on A5 is also
very safe it's hard to attack so that
move comes to mind and we could follow
up by playing Rook F to C8
and the positive of that approach is by
playing Rook C8 immediately we do drop
the A7 pawn and we don't just want to
give away Pawns in this position so
there's a lot of possibilities here we
can go A6 we can go A5 we can go Queen
to A5 now when possible I prefer piece
play over Pawn Play Just Because I think
it's easier to understand and it's more
instructive so we're actually going to
go Queen to A5 and it's a non-committal
move Queen A5 is a very non-committal
move we improve our position tangibly we
connect our Rooks and we leave our pawns
on their initial places because we don't
know exactly later on whether we'll want
to go A6 or A5
this move should be totally
understandable to everybody just putting
the queen in a good Square easy access
to the center later on we can go Queen
to C5 maybe and offer a queen trade try
to secure the D4 Square for our dark
squared Bishop
uh Queen to E5 is is also a later
possibility
yeah so
in these types of openings you should
also understand that allowing your
opponent to expand can be a good thing
for you if white plays A3 and B4 not
only is the A3 Pawn likely to hang but
the C4 Pawn is also going to be a lot
harder to defend right the only way to
defend that pawn with a pawn is to play
B3 so if you can induce B4 that's often
a good thing for you but players often
as I have said many many speed runs ago
the move that players fear the most
after a check especially newer players
are moves that attack your queen it's
just a phobia of facing a move that
attacks your queen remember that that is
just as harmless in most cases as any
other threat you can move your queen
so making a move to induce a weakness is
a very Advanced type of move that
players are often unwilling to make but
you should work on you know your
knee-jerk reaction to moves that attack
your queen now I'm not talking about
forks and moves that trap the queen
obviously they can be dangerous but they
aren't intrinsically dangerous
so note that we are not threatening to
take on C3 here because white can
recapture with the queen and then if we
take on A2 Our Queen does get trapped
with Rook to A1 Plus I really would not
want to give away the pride of our
position for a corner Pawn even if we
could get away with that in most cases
I'd like to keep our Bishop alive until
better opportunity comes along
so our next move is very likely to be
Rook F to C8
if white plays Knight to D5 that's also
why we positioned the bishop on E6 to
restrict the Knight and Knight D5 we
will definitely take that Knight and all
of White's Queen side pawns are going to
be hanging as a result so that's not
really an option for white
yeah Rook 88 is possible but the reason
I like Rook F to C8 is also because
later when we go A6 and B5 our rooked on
A8 could actually be a valuable piece
the a file could open up later and
keeping our pieces on the queen side is
a good idea we could also go A6 and put
the Rook on B8 to help prepare B5 so
when we go Rook FCA the other Rook does
have a role to play on the queen side
whereas if we do it the other way if we
go Rook ac8 not only do we have to you
know keep the a pawn protected by the
queen and that's a bit of a headache but
it would be harder to prepare A6 and B5
Rook A1 okay so our opponent is starting
to panic our opponent is starting to
panic
um
the reason I think he panicked is
because I think our opponent thought
that Bishop takes C3 was a threat so
actually here taking on C3 makes a lot
of sense because we would be permanently
crippling White's Queen Side Pawn
structure and those resulting pawns
would be total sitting ducks so Bishop
takes C3 and then Rook F to C8 would be
a great approach I think that would
probably be one of the best moves
but we could also play Rook F to C8
straight away the bad thing about Rook
A1 is that it invalidates B3 that move
is now no longer possible because the
night hangs right we're attacking it
twice and it's only being defended once
so after Rook F to C8 white actually
can't really even defend the C4 Pawn
because if white plays Knight D5 as
we've already discussed we snapped that
Knight off the board and then our dark
squared Bishop could travel to B2 land
and take that pawn away
so there's two possibilities here we can
start
by removing the knight from the board
and then playing Rook fc8
and then we would win the C4 pawn and
likely win another Pawn on C3
or or or
we could play the immediate Rook fc8 I
think both options are fantastic
um there is a concrete line I'm trying
to calculate here
yeah and I think it does work out for us
so let's go Rook fc8 let's go Rook fc8
so again
there is a reason that I didn't choose
Rook ac8 it's a Concrete line and I'll
show you after the game what I
calculated that there's a specific
situation maybe we'll get it in the game
in which the Rook on A8 believe it or
not I think an extra defender on the A7
Pawn becomes important in a particular
line and the line is after Knight D5
which I think is not unlikely Bishop
takes D5 e takes D5 Bishop takes B2 so
we attack The Rook on A1 The Rook moves
to B1 our Bishop drops back to F6 we're
gonna get this in the game right we're
gonna get this in the game
okay our opponent plays CD which I think
is a mistake because it opens up the C
file for us so this might render what
I'm telling you null and void because we
might get another option okay so here we
should pause for a second and establish
that we don't necessarily have to take
on B2 right away right there's ways to
try to squeeze more juice out of this
position so one thing that comes to mind
is Rook to C2 not only are we going
after the B2 Pawn but we're also
activating our rook and trying to
maximize the value of the open file so
we should calculate right Bishop takes
B2 white plays Rook a B1 and in that
position notice that Queen takes A2
would be a blunder who sees why who sees
why we can't take both Pawns in one Fell
Swoop what does white have in that
position
why does a very nasty little move right
so the yeah Queen E3 back to D2 and the
bishop on B2 is pinned and we lose the
bishop
all right so we can't take both pawns
what we can do is play Bishop takes B2
Rook a B1 and then drop our Bishop back
let's say to F6 and there you can see
why I wanted to keep a rook on A8
because if white takes on B7 in that
resulting position we can safely take
the pawn on A2 and A7 isn't hanging
right and we can actually just send that
pawn up the board I think we're gonna do
that in this for the sake of Simplicity
right this is a very simple way to play
maybe not the best computer option but
it gives black a huge advantage
so hopefully you can you can follow that
line in your head Rook a B1 Bishop F6
okay B1 Bishop F6
why Bishop F6 and not Bishop you know
somewhere else for another
straightforward reason after Rook takes
B7 E7 is also going to be hanging
otherwise so Bishop F6 is the only way
to circumvent that issue
right
um not that losing E7 would have even
been such a big deal I mean maybe even
sacrificing it would have been
interesting but if the E7 Pawn is taken
away then our King starts feeling a
little bit uncomfortable right if a
brook lands on E7 white could play Queen
F4 and start harassing the F7 Pawn it's
a headache we don't have to deal with
here
um
why does borderline lost in this
position another important positional
point is that uh opposite colored
Bishops is something that people often
associate with draws right you're often
taught that opposite colored Bishop end
games are drawn a lot of the time and
that's true right and I won't delve into
the reasons for that it is true that in
opposite colored Bishop end games right
when you've literally have one Bishop
for one side and one Bishop for the
other side and they're of different
colors
the drawing potential is huge and mostly
that is concerned with the fact that you
can easily set up a blockade on a
particular complex of squares right
because you have a monopoly on the light
squares for example and so you can
Envision a lot of situations where the
pawns reach a certain square and then
they just can't move forward and you
can't allow them to move forward because
you don't have the Machinery to do that
but in Middle games that could not be
further from the truth right an opposite
colored Bishop middle games you don't
have any of that drawing potential
because you've got the heavy pieces uh
to to support let's say pawns and you
also have a lot of attacking potential
because if you have complete control
over all of the dark squares you can
actually attack on the dark squares your
opponent doesn't have the defensive
Machinery to defend against that so I'm
really
I'm really belaboring the point but the
point is that you shouldn't be afraid of
opposite card Bishop middle games
because you can definitely win them all
right so Queen B3 this doesn't create a
threat I mean queen takes B7 is not a
threat because A2 hangs
but what we should avoid here is the
mubaruk to C3 maybe some of you are
thinking because after Queen takes B7
The Rook on 8 actually hangs
so the kind of Soviet Schoolboy move
would be B6 just eliminate the headache
of that pawn
um but there's some other moves that I
like here and I like a more aggressive
approach right so in general whenever a
piece moves from a square you should
always in the back of your head kind of
keep in mind which squares are now
available to your pieces right which
squares have been relinquished by your
opponent and this is especially true
when you've got very active pieces that
can infiltrate your opponent's territory
so one move that I love here is actually
Queen to D2
and you might say well is this risky
we're just sending our Queen into
unknown territory but here you can
really see how much we control the game
we're controlling the B2 Square
we're controlling the C file
even if the queen is chased away first
of all the bishop is hanging white has
to address that even if the queen is
chased away this is what I was saying
earlier the queen has a gazillion
different ways to retreat it can Retreat
to the king side to F4 it can Retreat to
the C file it can even Retreat back to
A5 so our Queen is perfectly safe here
it's got a million Escape Routes we
shouldn't be afraid of infiltrating
and what is the purpose of putting the
queen on D2 well it's just a great
Square we're still hitting the A2 Pawn
we're just forcing white to make
concessions right we're forcing white to
move the bishop
and if the bishop moves let's say to G4
then we can lift our Rook simply up to
C7 in order to protect the B7 Pawn and
then later we can try to stack the Rooks
on the C file we could expand a little
bit on the on the Kink side as well with
a move like H5
so wherever the bishop is going to go
it's going to be vulnerable to further
attacks
there's Bishop G4 now again I I don't
like Rook C2 because of Queen takes B7
and the rook in the corner hangs and
then you could say listen we could go
Rook C2 Queen takes B7 we can move the
rook and we could try to go after the F2
Pawn we could try to go from mate here
but it's unnecessary Rook C7 is a
perfectly safe
low risk option
and that Bishop on G4 this is what I was
saying is actually very vulnerable if
it's vulnerable to H5 it's vulnerable to
a move like Queen F4
which hits the bishop and hits the pawn
on e4
so to win these positions you have to be
very patient and you just gotta
accumulate the small advantages right
you do one thing and then you do another
thing and eventually you're going to get
your opportunity to infiltrate and
launch the decisive Invasion or idea or
whatever it is
right so you just need to kind of and
and this is also important because you
don't have to have a plan really in
these types of positions I don't have a
plan here I'm just sort of making
improving moves individually move by
move
with an eye toward you know being aware
of options decisive options when they
occur looking for tactics looking for
hanging pawns but largely I'm just sort
of accumulating my advantages here
it's it's a simple position to play here
actually it's a very easy position to
play to play reasonably well
yeah so I'm expecting Rook F to D1 or
Rook B to D1 and queen F4 looks like a
is calling my name there Queen F4 and
then maybe once the bishop moves from
this diagonal probably back to F3 to
protect the four Pawn then we can stack
the Rooks on C8
and that's good because then we have you
know on demand we can we can infiltrate
the second Rank and that might already
be the beginning of the end
if white plays F3 that's actually what
we want because F3 does a couple of
things it it weakens the A7 G1 diagonal
and Bishop D4 could come with a check
later in the game but it also weakens
the second rank so once we go Rook C2 we
will have direct access to the G2 pawn
and that already is a precursor to a
mating attack so let's go Queen F4 let's
go Queen F4 aiming at a bunch of
important pawns and trying to knock the
bishop off of the diagonal
yeah so black white can also play Queen
F3 here and then we'll have a choice we
do not have to trade Queens we
absolutely don't have to trade Queens we
could drop our Queen a little bit
further back to G5 but I think we will
trade Queens
because if white plays G takes F3 there
well that's that those are more
weaknesses on the king side that we
could explain and I also really want to
kind of showcase how to convert an end
game advantage of this sort so I like
the the option of taking on F3 I love
the option of going Queen G5 that might
allow us to win the game faster
and I do have to go very soon as soon so
I it's kind of in my best interest to
win fast
yeah let's let's keep the Queens on the
board and you know as long as you
understand that Queen takes F3 there is
a perfectly viable alternative it's it's
a matter of taste
but I I wanna I wanna finish him off
here sooner rather than later
yeah we're grinding this one down
no I don't think it would be terribly
difficult to convert the end game
that will be by the way in in a chapter
in
one an end game video obviously called
Bishop Ben games that's that's going to
be analyzed in detail
now we've got all of the same threats
that we would have if the queens were
off the board so if if we had traded on
F3 we actually probably would have just
gone Rook to C2 and gone after the a
pawn and once we remove the a pawn we
just run our passer up the board it
would be totally Unstoppable in a
classical game against the GM I would
trade Queens here and go Rook C2 no
question about it but we still have the
same concept in this position we want to
go Rook C2 as some of you are pointing
out Rook to C3 is also a very nasty
threat but we just want to go Rook C2
win the A2 pawn and promote our a pawn
it's as simple as that we don't give a
damn about white taking on B7 anymore
because the E7 Pawn is well protected
the seventh rank gives white nothing
here
so
yeah the wind the wind is very
straightforward here we need to back
back our opponent goes back which is a
good move our opponent stops Rook C2 so
kudos for for some resilient defense so
I think that we should throw in the move
H5 without even a second thought it's
it's a helpful move because it grabs
some space on the king side you also
might know that this Pawn structure F7
G6 H5 is often considered to be a a
model or ideal Pawn structure in a lot
of end games because the pawns protect
each other and they're not on the same
rank I know this is like way in the
future but the reason this is
recommended is often because the pawns
are hard to win like your opponent can
only take one of them at one time with a
rook whereas if they're in the same rank
you could just snap them off the board
by going to one particular rank so this
is more important usually in Rook end
games but it's it's just one of those
small things to keep in mind F7 G6 H5
you'll often see GM's kind of arranging
their pawns that way because you're
looking talking toward the future toward
the end game Bishop H3 good move
preventing Rook ACA our opponent
defending very well here I have to say
okay so that means we should slow it
down a little bit
and we should continue making gradual
and small improving moves I definitely
should have traded queens that would
have been
more efficient
so I will acknowledge that was probably
an inaccuracy on my part for sure
I to be completely honest I missed
Bishop H3 like I didn't realize our
opponent could continue preventing us
from doubling on the C file which would
end the game immediately because once we
hit hit the C2 squared it just ends the
game so we just we should be very
patient here
yeah Rook C3 is a very good looking move
to threaten Rook takes Bishop right
because the g-pawn is pinned but I I
don't like one move threats like that I
think we should continue improving
and the move I I really want to make
here is B6 right I I want to eliminate
the headache of the B7 Pawn so that our
Rook is free to roam about the cabin
Rook C3 is not as good as some people
think it is because I think white has
this move G3
and G3 intercepts the contact The Rook
is making with the bishop and It
prepares the move F4 and if we allow G3
and F4 Our Queen is going to be banished
to H6 and yeah white will weaken his
King but it will not be the ideal
scenario so if white plays G3 here first
of all be impressed because that is a
high level move to to kind of push upon
in front of your own King like that is
not easy to do
um but we will need to find some way to
respond to the positional threat of f4
G3 play okay
so
what are we going to do here well let me
think for a second
I have a very interesting idea
it's kind of creative
so here's what we're gonna do
I I think at a high level this is
something I've talked about previously
when we talk about prophylaxis and
prophylaxis is the fancy chest term for
stopping your opponent's threats there
is essentially two types of prophylaxis
I call it type 1 and type 2 prophylaxis
type 1 prophylaxis is physically is
preventing the possibility of a move
right so what would be an example of
type 1 prophylaxis here it would be the
move Bishop to E5
it physically stops that Fort why you
can still play it but it's a bad move
because we take on F4 with the bishop
the g-pawn is pinned the problem with
Bishop E5 is that it's a Band-Aid and
white could slide their King over to H1
and not only will F4 the threat be
renewed but it will be an even more
powerful threat because then it will win
a piece but there is also type 2
prophylaxis which is you allow the move
to happen but in some sense you take the
sting out of it or you make a move such
that uh the effectiveness of a
particular move has been diminished in
some way so what's an example of that
and this is the move we're going to play
what do I notice about the move F4 well
first of all it weakens White's King
second of all it does weaken this G3
Pawn so what move can we make to
preemptively put a little bit of
pressure on the G3 pawn and try to
discourage white from playing F4 or at
least
you know further the consequences of
that move we play H4
and if you look at this move you might
say well I don't understand like we're
not winning the G3 Pawn right now it's
very well protected but if white plays
F4 we drop our Queen back to H6 we
x-rayed the bishop on H3 and we then
threaten to play H takes G3 and win the
bishop and maybe also you could consider
the idea of sliding the king up and
deploying The Rook to h8 so opening up
the H file could result in a checkmating
attack
and of course white does not have to go
F4 but then we're chilling and we could
follow up with a move like Rook C3 here
you know hit hit that G3 Pawn where it
hurts
so type 2 prophylaxis
very important tool tool in your tool
bag okay our opponent offers the queen
trade
giving us a second chance to write the
wrongs
at this point I think trading makes a
lot of sense it still bums me out that
we can't go Rook ac8
and so we might have to give up control
of the C file but that's really not a
big deal it's really not a big deal Rook
C4 is a possibility we could tickle the
E4 Pawn first but let's let's really
just get down to business here and play
Rook C2 let's let's get down to business
and and and try to win the say two pawn
and end the game because
even if we give up the C file that
really means nothing
yeah to defeat the Hunts
you know what's funny is if white plays
A4 the best move there I think is not
Rook A2 the bishop can defend the A4
Pawn from D7 that's also a nasty idea
because C6 is an outpost we should be
aware of
does anybody see what the best move is
after A4
spotting undefended pawns and pieces
right you always have to be aware of
where the undefended pawns are Rook C2
back to C4
and what's funny is we should start with
Rook C3 here same concept we're just
driving the pawn forward and then we're
moving back to C4 I love these types of
ideas and if white defends with Rook A1
well we could still play Rook C4 and
open up a discovered attack on The Rook
if I ever draw that Arrow properly
no the game is over
the game is over because once we win the
A3 Pawn or even the E4 Pawn white cannot
survive this position two pawns down
because everything else is just gonna
start collapsing
yeah so this is this is over
so the morosi bind has been destroyed
successfully
and this became a pretty one-sided game
yeah Rook C4 after White
allowed us to take that dark squared
Bishop those those positions become very
very hard to handle
those positions become very hard to
handle
what do you do if Rook A1 well Rook A1
notice that that square is protected by
the bishop okay now this move
uh is a good thought by our opponent the
thing is we don't give a single damn
that these pawns are doubled in fact
this is what we want even with one a
pawn I would prefer this position to be
without the A7 Pawn because then a rook
would actually support A5 but this is
completely winning as it is
much worse would have been Rook takes E4
because the bishop drops back to F3
there attacking the rook and white would
win the B6 Pawn
allowing all of the pawns to be on the
same flank those positions are much
harder to win than when you have an
outside passer on the other side of the
board
yeah Bishop D7 was the last chance but
it was still lost and now
without a second thought we just push we
could play H takes G3 first it really
doesn't matter I don't care if white
takes on H4 we won't even recapture with
the bishop in fact we want to keep our
Bishop
planted on this diagonal and you'll see
why in a second
just without just push forward A3
the reason is that if white stops the
pawn from in front with Rook A2 we could
stick that Bishop on B2
and The Rook is permanently arrested so
it'll take us a couple more moves to win
this game but it's it's all over
E4 okay so well we have a million ways
to win here but the elegant move here is
Bishop B2 this is the elegant way to win
you're intercepting the connection
between the rook and the next Square
We're Not Afraid Of The Exchange
sacrifice which our opponent might play
yeah but because this just wins an
overwhelming amount of tier we could
send our other Pawn up the board but if
again if you want to play like a Russian
Schoolboy why not take this Pawn First
there's no hurry the a pawn isn't going
anywhere let's just take another Pawn
just in case
take on e4 first be patient
when with an abundance of of caution now
rookie 3 allows King F2 so let's just
keep our Rook on D4
doesn't matter we we're happy to give up
the seven Pawn as well
and you don't have to overdo this so if
if our opponent goes Rook B7 we we
certainly don't have to play King f8
there and protect every one of our pawns
at some point you could just send the a
pawn up the board okay this is
resignable
okay Rook B4 is a nice move because it
offers The Rook trade and
allows us to push the pawn more
efficiently
yeah total full send our Pawn's gonna
get to A3 and in the event that white
stops it from A2
hopefully you know the drill you just go
Rook B2 and you keep offering The Rook
trade to force the Rook away from its
blockading Square this is the kind of
super common mechanism
so this was a smooth win
with maybe the one exception that I
should have traded Queens first when we
had a chance now I don't unfortunately I
don't have much time so I'm gonna have
to rush the analysis just a little bit
but we're going to get more chances to
to look at the theory of the morosi bind
so don't feel like this is our last
morosi bind game I'm going to kind of
give a couple General thoughts on this
line
um so again Bishop G7 is the main move
this is the most popular line and this
goes Knight F6 Knight C3 now there is
this move Knight G4 which is kind of a
tactical line
um but the tactics work out for black
here because if white takes the Knight
then we take it the other night and if
white takes C6 then this is actually bad
because we can take the bishop so
there's a lot of options here on the
menu and you don't have to play what I'm
recommending but I I really think the
Knight F6 is the best line for
intermediate beginner intermediate
players
so first important tactical detail is
that if white takes and plays E5 we have
Queen A5 check for King The King and the
pawn then we pick up the pawn with check
and we're chilling so Knight C3 is
virtually forced virtually forced then
we play Knight takes D4 Queen takes D4
and D6 and it is possible for white to
play E5 here this is a move that has
been played by some strong players but
this end game down upon is better for
black white has insufficient
compensation according to the engine
I've looked at this it's probably equal
if white plays accurately but this is
nothing to be afraid of in fact I think
the only move that keeps like chances
for equality is just like Bishop E2
and according to the engine black
deploys the bishop to E6 much like we
did in the game
and if White Castles it's important not
to be afraid of The Rook coming to D1
here I like the engine recommendation
Knight to D7 covering the C5 Square so
immobilizing the C4 Pawn
and now if white plays Rook to D1
the other idea of Knight D7 is that we
can expand a little bit on the king side
with F5 nice pawns here and the point is
that Bishop F3 can be met now with E4
sending the bishop back
so you can analyze this further but this
is nothing to be afraid of especially if
you analyze this end game a little bit
obviously if white takes back on E5 then
Bishop G7 is totally fine for black so
Bishop B2 is is one of the main moves
castles castles and now the big mistake
by white of course is to play Bishop E3
um now
in terms of the theory let me check what
the most popular move is in this
position the most popular move in this
position for white
is to play I think it's to move the
queen let me see yeah it's actually
Queen to D3 this is the most popular
move getting out of the X-ray and here
the main line continues Bishop E6 but
Magnus Carlson uh has played the move A5
here this is like the the move that's
been popular in the last couple of years
among GM's and I explained the idea of
this move earlier you're trying to push
the pawn to A4 and make it harder for
white to play the move B3 because if
white plays B3 immediately can anybody
spot why this move is wrong if white
plays this move with an undefended Rook
on A1
then white black not A4 A4 is good but
there's a better move and it's Knight
takes E4 this is a tactic you have to
remember if you're an accelerated Dragon
player you have to be aware of this
possibility it exists also in the king's
Indian by the way so if the queen takes
then we take on C3 and we win a pawn and
to add insult to injury white can easily
lose another exchange here
but very importantly if Knight takes C4
we take the rook and if the bishop had
been developed then white would have
been able to take on A1 that is horrible
for black here Bishop H6 is nicely met
with Bishop G7 and is our King totally
out of the woods no but we are up and
exchanging upon and white really can't
cause many problems for our King right
this check is not scary just don't be
afraid to play F6 here and you know
develop the little Pawn cocoon this is
just winning for black
so for this reason white needs to get
the bishop out first let's say Bishop E3
this is the most popular move and now of
course black plays A4 although Carlson
played Bishop to D7 here so I'll need to
do a little bit of analysis here uh in
preparation for the next accelerated
video and then really settle on a
recommendation but this line is pretty
good
now the top engine move is Bishop to D4
and now black continues the queen side
expansion with Queen A5 and if you flip
on the engine in these types of
positions it does give a small Advantage
for white but the point is it's a very
easy position to mishandle because white
has you know white can essentially bite
off more than they can chew
the main move here is F4 but way Yi
played Rook a to D1 which is a bit of a
weird move and here you can play Bishop
E6 or you can play Bishop to D7 and
deploy it to C6 which I think is the top
computer recommendation
there was a game between a 2400 and a 20
100 that went F4 and here the best
response would have been to continue
with the plan Bishop C6 just a very rich
position where black has a lot of active
ideas Bishop F3 for example now you can
go Rook F to d8
this looks like a mysterious Rook move
right why put the Rook on a closed file
but if white makes you know a random
move then we already play E5 explode the
center and give our pieces fantastic
squares this is an exception to the rule
by the way I did say be careful about E5
but obviously here white loses the
bishop and so white has to move the
bishop and then we remove the pawn from
E5 and we use that E5 Square Frankfurt
airport Type move as a an outpost for R9
I mean look how active Black's Bishops
are crisscrossing the board A3 is a
threat uh another common idea in the
accelerated to undermine the Knight and
you're obviously not afraid of of this
because of Knight E5 and White's pieces
are totally discombobulated so this can
get very very unpleasant for white very
quickly of course white can play the
more modest F3 but you still continue
with Bishop C6 and this is the sort of
one exception to the rule about trading
dark squared Bishops there are
situations in the accelerated dragon
we're training dark squared Bishops is
actually good for black and the reason
is that the king is quite safe here
white doesn't have any attacking forces
on the king side and white just has to
suffer with a very bad light squared
Bishop which is staring at its own pawns
and black can continue pressuring the
queen side with Queen B6 and Rook ac8
the Knight can come out to E5 and these
are positions that I will explore in a
lot more depth in subsequent videos
um because there's a lot of ideas to
know here but hopefully this just gives
you a very general sense of how these
positions are played Bishop G5 is
another possibility here as I said
during the game but the bishop can be
chased away with H6 and if white plays
Bishop H4 then we can go G5 and how do
we win this well we don't win this
bishop we trade it with Knight H5 oh
trading the Knight for the dark squid
Bishop is almost always good for black
this is a slightly worse version because
obviously black is made some weaknesses
on the king side but the engine still
likes Black's position and so do I here
we play as we did in the game and you're
never afraid of f4 because Queen B6
check just wins the B2 pawn and the game
uh so white has to be very cautious
about opening up his King when in the
absence of the dark squid Bishop so
Bishop B3 Knight G4 is automatic Bishop
E6 is automatic and already I think
black is slightly better here
I think White's best move in this
position Rook A1 is honestly the
beginning of the end like after Rook fc8
I think White's position is borderline
indefensible
probably white should have gone B3 here
and if we play Bishop takes C3 then we
should probably refrain from grabbing
that pawn because white can run the F
Bond up the board and hopefully you can
see how dangerous this could get you
know Queen H6 and then Rook H3 becomes a
problem
so stay away from this much more to the
point here
would be a move like Rook ac8 or you
know even Rook fe8 is a good move the
engine likes this type of move because
you take the sting out of the move
Knight D5 now this move can be met with
Bishop takes D5 e takes D5 Queen takes
A2 whereas earlier the E7 Pawn would
have been hanging so then you can play
A6 and Rook C8 and B5 and black is is
super super comfortable here so again I
won't spend too long on this but Rook A1
is is a great example of why I like
these positions for black because people
just don't know what to do here they get
the morosi bind they do what is
recommended but then they stare at it
and they say well what how do I improve
my position whereas black has very
clearly defined plans which we will
expand on in in subsequent videos of
course
um so Rook fc8 and again why did we
choose to keep the Rook on A8 because in
this line
after Rook takes B7 Queen takes A2 the
pawn is protected and we can just run it
up the board
we can just run it up the board
um our opponent decided to exacerbate
the situation yeah the engine does
actually like Rook C2 here this was even
stronger
um we could play Rook C2 here now there
was nothing wrong with this move but I
was a little bit worried that a rook
would get disattached from the bishop
this apparently does work for black but
I don't like situations where you've got
like a queen defending the rook and then
the Rook defends the bishop these are
the situations you want to avoid when
possible because there's a very high
probability of blundering something but
because we've got full dark Square
control white can't chase The Rook away
from D2 the best that white can do is
something like this that gives The Rook
an escape hatch and then we can bring
the other Rook to see it so this is just
winning for black oh A2 is also falling
and this is a disaster notice that after
Rook B1 Queen takes a two queen D2 a
cool little tactic that I'll actually
end with and then we'll wrap up does
anybody see how black can get out of
this earlier I mentioned that this loses
for black but the situation has changed
and here there's a very pretty Tactical
solution
well the back rank is weak right that
everybody should see that
by the way that's another thing that's
never talked about about the accelerated
Dragon the move G6 creates Luft for the
king so you almost never have to deal
with back rank weaknesses and that
really can't help you this is a winning
end game because you've got connected
passers and I was all indicating the
opposite color Bishop video coming out
maybe a month from now
these pawns supported by the King which
is going to walk over to the king side
there's no way that white can save this
end game and you can you know good thing
to do if you're watching on YouTube is
is to set this position up and analyze
it with an engine for 10 minutes right
you'll learn a lot about how to play
obstacle Bishop end games small things
that you can do to improve your
understanding it's not that hard right
as long as you you have the patience to
do those types of things anyways we
decided to play it more more
straightforwardly the queen came out and
obviously again I really think that I
should have taken the queen and played
Rook to C2 I think this this end game is
just dead white is just dead here
because there's no way to stop the a
pawn is supported by a rook from behind
and a rook from in front this is like
the ideal setup for the Rooks
um which doesn't happen often it happens
only when you obviously need to have
both of your Rooks
so
I don't think the results of the game
was ever in question we played it
patiently and I really think that white
should have played F4 and probably then
played King to G2 to protect the bishop
this maybe was White's last chance to
stay in the game
but a move like King G7 here just looks
really nasty because we're bringing the
Rook to h8 and the type 2 prophylaxis
concept something you should take away
white can never move G4 because F4 hangs
so Rook h8 is going to create the nasty
threat of opening up the H file and
going after the bishop so there were
ways to stay in the game for white but
ultimately it was virtually indefensible
and after we go Rook C2 we go after the
pawn
we win the pawn and then we just promote
our Apon so the technical task was
straightforward
and this is where we'll wrap up folks I
apologize for rushing through the
analysis just a little bit but I I'm
heading off to Raleigh for the North
Carolina state championship
where I'll be I'll be coaching some some
Charlotte kids thank you flaming
cornbrezo hopefully people understand
congrats to Magnus and I
we'll see you guys later thanks for
hanging out everybody hope you enjoyed
the stream I'll see everybody on Sunday
bye
[Music]